now of course we've got to ask you about
kick-ass you worked with before her
intelligence Ihnen but what was it like
working with those guys and what is it
about the kick-ass world I try to do I
liked I liked the whole idea of the
world I thought I was a unique version
of a superhero movie which is what I
liked and I wasn't playing some sort of
stereotypical girlfriend of a superhero
it seemed unique and relatable and
working with them was wonderful it was
when I shot it it was my first time in
London at the time so it was a whole new
country a whole new experience I didn't
know I knew Christopher mintz-plasse but
it wasn't it was a whole new thing so
it's always really scary but it was a
really wonderful experience of course
you swear you bat for kick-ass too as
well how is it working with Jeff Wadlow
compared to Matthew hold on the first
movie very different totally different
Jeff is you know American and younger
and he just kind of speaks more my
language but they were both fantastic
and unique in their own way I mean it's
hard to compare because it's like apples
and oranges you know but Jeff was
fantastic
and of course ISM had seen in the books
the original comic books that doesn't
make it into the the second movie I mean
what did you feel about that kind of
very violent seeing that your character
had in the comic book world that didn't
make into the film I don't know I feel
like there's a lot of violence in both
movies and I just don't think you can
have everything you know there's got to
be a plot and a story and it's hard to
tell all of that stuff in in a film and
in a comic book you can just keep
turning the pages so it's a little bit
more difficult in that medium so now how
likely are we to see back for kick-ass 3
which we're all looking forward to let's
face it um I mean it's in such a
beginning stages that nobody no I have
no idea how much would you like to be
back there with them all oh I'd love it
like a family I'd love that
you